tout le monde a un halloween dont ils se souviendront toujours
et
c'est la
[musique] de
jake jake vous dans le vintage non je suis dans le rétro
oh quelle est la différence à propos de 10 dollars
assez juste
[musique]
regardez que quelqu'un a pris le
couteau de boucher
salut
je suis  chucky tu veux jouer
jake tu vas bien je ne supporte pas l'ensemble de
la chatte de sang
oh non jake ce n'est pas tout à fait raison
ce qui t'est arrivé jake
tu avais l'habitude d'avoir des amis
n'oublie pas ton jouet de garçon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique  ] d'
accord
c'est contagieux n'est-ce pas rire des
gens
eh bien devinez quels connards maintenant la blague est
sur vous
salut
je suis chuck
et je suis ton ami jusqu'à la fin
qu'as-tu fait
maman dit que le vrai meurtre est mauvais ouais eh bien
maman est pleine de merde
regarde autour de toi c'est la série mondiale du
massacre
[Musique]
as-tu senti que
partout où va Jake Wheeler, la mort
semble suivre une
poupée effrayante qui me fait juste peur
c'est tuer ou être tué tout le monde doit
choisir
ce qui se passe avec toi
tu ne croirais pas  moi si je te disais
chucky il est parti mec  tu as un
problème de style secret si tu sais seulement
hey gamin je vais aller tuer ta soeur tu
veux venir tu as sommeil
tu roupilles tu te perds